- I did a deep dive on her,
musically, she is incredible.
- She--
- Like such a great storyteller,
love her lyrics,
there's this one song "Blue"
- Mhm.
that I saw that you posted
and I literally was like,
"this is, I love this lyric."
It's from "Blue"
and it's called
"Just another thing you say,
it's only a little bit true."
Who's been in that relationship?
(host and audience laugh)
Like, it's like so interesting.
- Yeah, she's in this band called Thea
- Yeah!
- She's @mckennaleah
- Yeah.
- And her partner is @reahgarden
and they are Thea
and the album's called "July".
They have a new song
coming out April 15th
and I'm not promoting at all!
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] No, you should,
it's super cool.
- You know,
she played this,
Krista Reedus,
who is Casey RW here,
I'm sure you know,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
like, Morning Becomes Eclectic.
He put her on the air,
Chris Mikely at SiriusXM
put them on the air, them,
and then he does this thing
called "school night",
and they performed
and you know,
I'm her mom,
I'm gonna like
whatever they do
- [Kelly] Yeah.
but they started
and everybody in her life
looked at each other like,
"I think this is like a real thing,
like this is happening."
- It's like,
ethereal sadness,
it's like beautiful,
- [Host] They are sad, beautiful songs.
I love it,
that's my favorite.
- Yeah, that's your favorite.
- And I think that's
a great escapism too,
that's why we,
you know,
gravitate towards music
and they're such a mood.
- And the two of them
write the songs together
and they,
I just hear them downstairs like
laughing or they'll
write some sad lyric
and then I hear,
"That's cool."
(audience laughs)
- Do you as a mom,
cause I've never,
I'm the artist at this point
so I can't imagine
having a kid
write some of those lyrics.
- It's mind blowing.
- Is that hard for you
to listen,
like it's like sad?
- Oh, that it's sad?
- Oh, often before
she'll play me one she's like,
"This is all made up."
- Just disclaimer.
- So I just like,
I'm just gonna believe you.
- Nothing about this is true.
- No.
Certainly not about me.
- That's a good play.